[Music]
hey you guys
tomes of terror time once again and
again we have a really
really good one you guys seriously need
to read this one
this one is called cold moon
over babylon by michael mcdowell
now this is actually the second michael
mcdowell book that i've read and
reviewed
if you remember a while back a few
months ago i think i did
the elementals and i
you know really need my horror cred
revoked because i had not heard and i
went a little bit into this on my
elementals video but i hadn't heard of
michael mcdowell
prior to seeing a review of the
elementals on a booktube channel that i
watch all the time
and i'm like wow that sounds fantastic
so that was kind of like the first one i
bought and i loved it
and subsequently when i was doing
research for that video i found out that
michael mcdowell is actually
something of a cult figure i guess in
the uh horror fiction community
he was real he wrote um a [ __ ] ton of
paperback horror like during the
paperback horror boom in the 70s and 80s
not only under his own name but he wrote
under uh several different pseudonyms as
well
he also uh probably most famously wrote
the first draft of the screenplay for
beetlejuice and also the one for
nightmare before christmas which is
probably where a lot of people uh gnomes
they hyped that up a lot because that
was kind of like a famous thing
that he did but i guess and
you remember a couple weeks back when i
reviewed a grady hendricks book and i
mentioned paperbacks from hell the book
that he wrote
that was about the the paperback horror
boom of the 70s and 80s
and he talked a little bit about michael
mcdowell in there and um
you know stephen king was a big fan uh
peter straub i believe called him like
you know the best uh writer of horror
paperbacks
uh going and uh i will definitely
back that up because as i said this is
only the second book of his that i read
but i
loved loved this one now the elementals
uh this
came a little bit later i believe i
think this actually cold mood over
babylon i think was his second novel
and uh like the elementals it's a
southern gothic this one's not quite as
weird
as the elementals but it has some of the
same um
you know some of the same aspects to it
because michael mcdowell who sadly
passed away in 1999 it signed up sort of
a young age
unfortunately he was from alabama so a
lot of his
books are set in alabama this one is
actually
set in a town called babylon which is
actually in the florida panhandle
not that far from the florida alabama
line
i'm not sure if it's a real town or not
i mean i'm from i've lived in florida
pretty much my whole life but it's like
i've only been in the panhandle maybe
once or twice uh during that whole
entire time so i'm not real familiar
with that area but it is called like
alabama south because there's not really
a lot of difference
now as i said this is a pulpy i don't
know that sounds dismissive but
i mean pulpy in a good way it's like a
paperback horror novel from like you
know the 70s the 80s this actually was
came out in 1980 but recently like in
the past few years vallencourt
uh publishing has been putting out uh
new editions
of uh of a lot of his stuff because like
i said he seems to have
uh be having something of a resurgence
which i'm really really happy about
because like his
his stuff is like really really good and
i'm amazed that i hadn't heard
of him before now because i just
deserved to be slapped for that but
whatever
but i'm getting to it now so i promise
and i actually have i bought another one
of his books too called the amulet
and i'll be reviewing that at some point
he also a lot of people seem to like
he wrote like a series of novels called
blackwater the blackwater series
and i believe they sell that all in one
uh
one volume now so i'll probably be
getting to that as well but i think the
amulet will probably be the next michael
mcdowell that i do because i actually
have bought that i just haven't read it
yet but so what you have with this one
as i said like
uh like the elementals this is a
southern gothic
that's based in a small town
and is based around kind of a series of
interconnected families
so there's this little town called
babylon as i said which is in the
florida panhandle
and at the beginning of the book there's
actually a little bit of a prologue
where uh jim and joanne larkin
back in 1965 i believe are out
fishing um on a river called the styx
river like stick says and the one that
flows through
the underworld you know that's so you
know is it
it's a bad it's a bad omen probably
naming your river that but
just saying so they're fishing on the
river and they come across
a croaker sack and they uh it
turns out that it's full of rattlesnakes
and the two of them um you know get bit
and they fall in the river and they
drown
and their bodies are never recovered so
then you jump forward to
the present day or at least the present
day of this book which is 1980.
now they had two children uh who were
you know very young at the time
jerry and margaret now jerry and
margaret are now i believe
jerry is 19 or 20 or 21 somewhere around
there
and margaret is 14 and they are living
with their grandmother
evelyn on the farm where they all lived
it's actually a blueberry farm
now at the beginning of the novel you're
kind of like
one thing i will say about this is that
the description
of and i think i mentioned this when i
was talking about the elementals too
michael mcdowell is a [ __ ] genius
when it comes to just immersing you in
the world that he's created you can see
it you can smell it you can taste it
it's just he's really really good it's
so so descriptive
and like a lot of the descriptive
language is just really really beautiful
it's like almost poetic
so when you're reading this book you can
really just kind of
put yourself in the town like you know i
could see it as
plain as day um though you know just the
way he described it
so they have this blueberry farm which
has been sustaining them for a while
but you know they've been starting to
have some problems uh the
you know the blueberry plants aren't
producing the way they used to
uh there's been bad rains uh you know so
and they're kind of behind on a lot of
their bills
so they're not really sure how many more
seasons they're going to be able to
sustain uh the the farm and uh evelyn
the grandmother is kind of worried about
it and jerry
who has uh you know come to an age where
he's very young but he's
you know kind of the man of the house i
guess and uh so he's kind of worrying
about it as well
now at the very beginning of the book
now i will say i'm not gonna spoil
everything about this but
it's really really hard to talk about
this book without you know spoiling some
plot points
and i will say that even though
nominally this is a murder mystery
it's not really because even though a
bunch of murders take place
you find out who the killer is pretty
much from the jump like in the
first third of the book so it's not
really a miss like a whodunit type of
thing
uh which is kind of unusual because i
was actually surprised like when i was
like oh okay we're finding out
we're finding out who killed her already
all right but uh yeah so
and from that point forward it becomes a
vengeful ghost
story so it's not so don't go into it
expecting it to be like a whodunit like
you're gonna figure out who the killer
is they're gonna tell you who the killer
is like almost immediately
because that's not really what this book
is doing this book is more
about a supernatural revenge
type of story not really so much a
murder mystery
so almost from the beginning of the book
like you know like i said other than the
prologue where it said like they talked
about their parents dying
in the in the sticks like with the
rattlesnakes and whatnot that you know
when they jump ahead to 1980
so they're kind of like establishing the
town a little bit
establishing how long his family's been
there and establishing the problems
they're having with the blueberry farm
and then it turns out that margaret the
14 year old
she um has been at the school like
helping out a teacher after school or
whatever
and she leaves to go back to the farm on
her bike very very close to
where the farm is there's a little
bridge over the styx river
which is you know within shouting
distance of her house
while she's crossing over this bridge a
dude drives by her in a big black
hearse you know with fishing poles
sticking out of the back
and then when she's almost to the edge
of the bridge
a person jumps out of the bushes
basically dressed
all in black i think he doesn't have a
shirt on but he has like a really really
hairy chest or whatever
and he has almost kind of like it's not
like he was scrambling like a [ __ ] mask
he had like a [ __ ] mask
on and basically he
kind of stabs her sort of lit and then
he
ties her to her bike and throws her and
the bike into the river
so she drowns now as i said it's kind of
a mystery at first
you know who killed her but you find out
pretty soon
now after margaret is thrown into the
river
they go um michael mcdowell goes into
obviously her uh grandmother and her
brother wondering where the hell she is
there's a terrible terrible storm
um you know the night that she
disappears they're like well maybe she
stopped somewhere and she's staying at
someone's house you i mean you the
reader
know that she's already dead um which
actually makes their
reactions to her disappearance and them
trying to figure out like you know we're
trying to justify
how maybe she could be okay somewhere is
like makes it really heartbreaking
because
another thing that he's really great at
is
making you care about these characters
he's very good at
making the characters very distinct and
even though this is a southern gothic
and you know a southern gothic a lot of
times the characters are kind of a
little bit
exaggerated or like a little bit over
the top which they also were in the
elementals but in a fun way
um they're not quite as exaggerated in
this except maybe there's
one girl named belinda who's like a
teenager and she's kind of
you know she's kind of exaggerated a
little bit but this one not so much
um it does have kind of the same uh
it's it's funny because i guess because
he grew up in alabama
so he's very good at capturing uh the
cadence of that of the way that they
talk and like that dialogue and stuff
like that
you know that part of the south so
that's like really good too so the
characters in this are not quite as
you know over the top as they were in
the elementals but it's a similar kind
of
thing so only a day or two after the
disappearance
um you know after they've you know
obviously she hasn't come back
and they've kind of resigned themselves
to
you know the fact that something bad
happened to her so they contact the
sheriff
the sheriff is initially he's not a bad
guy his name is ted hale the character
but he just doesn't really i mean this
is a tiny sleepy little town
nothing bad ever happens here really
except you know he has to pull apart
some people like
they get in fights and drunk and stuff
but it's like there's not murders
and he's like when no one would want to
kill her so he doesn't really take it
all that seriously so she probably just
ran off with a boy somewhere
even though she's only 14 years old but
that's kind of what they were thinking
so he doesn't really take it all that
seriously
now not too long after uh the sheriff
gets involved like i said he's not
really
super investigating because he just
thinks she ran off somewhere
but then there's a guy who's fishing
under the bridge in the styx river and
his uh fish hook catches on the inside
of margaret's
mouth and he pulls her out so they find
the body
now not too long after they find the
body evelyn the grandmother
has a dream that margaret is
getting married and that
she can't see the groom at first but
then she sees margaret
get into the car like the limousine or
whatever and she's driving she's banging
on the back window
and then at the end of the dream she
sees uh the groom
and she she's kind of superstitious so
she believes that this dream is telling
her
who the person was that really killed uh
her granddaughter
now initially no one's really sure
like who to suspect at first really the
only person they
kind of think is maybe a possibility is
warren perry who was the teacher at the
school that she was helping
because they're like well he was the
last person to see her you know what was
she doing helping him some people said
she had a crush on him all this other
kind of stuff
but they didn't really they didn't have
any evidence obviously and um you know
they didn't really have anything to go
on but that was kind of all they
knew because they had never seen a
murder like this like who would
you know who would take a little girl
and tie her to a bike and throw her into
a
you know into a thing so she would drown
into the river so she would drown
so they had you know they had never like
had any experience with this type of
thing before but evelyn comes to them
and she said because of her dream and
because of some other things too
uh which i'll get into in a minute she
is convinced
that the person who killed her
granddaughter was this dude named nathan
redfield now nathan redfield
is the president of the bank of babylon
his dad actually owns the bank and this
and nathan is his son he also has
another son named ben who's younger
and the two of those brothers are kind
of like you know they're like the rich
boys in town
they live in the biggest nicest house
and um you know they're
they kind of get away with everything
nathan really really wanted to be bank
president but then he's kind of like
kind of a lazy ass too and he's also
kind of a dick and it turns out
that once he took over the bank from his
dad because his dad was in like an
accident or something like that and he
can't really get around all that well
anymore because he's in a wheelchair now
so he's been getting all over uh
evelyn the grandmother for
her like not being caught up with her
loan payments
and then it comes to light later that
there might be some reason that he
maybe wants their property so obviously
evelyn has this dream and she's like you
know he's been
you know [ __ ] on me about like you
know getting on me about like paying
this loan even though i'm not that far
behind
and you know he's being kind of shitty
to me so i think that he killed my
granddaughter obviously nobody believes
her
because they're like look there's no
there's no evidence of that we can't go
accusing like one of the richest people
in town
of killing somebody when we don't have
any evidence he didn't have any motive
he needed any reason anything like that
so it kind of goes on like that and then
there comes a point and like i said from
here on i don't really want to spoil it
because i think it's better
if you're not really because this goes
in some ways
that i really did not expect in the
sense that
people okay this is all i'm going to say
that people that you don't really
expect are going to die die you know
what i mean
it's kind of like because a couple times
when i was reading this i was like what
the
[ __ ] i was like really and it was like
and i wasn't even that far into the book
and i'm just like holy crap i can't
believe you just [ __ ] did that
like he really like pulls the rug out of
you like uh on a few
occasions and uh and it was kind of
awesome it's like
sad and it's like heartbreaking because
a lot of these characters
you know it's a whole town worth of
characters and they're kind of all
interrelated and stuff
and you really kind of get to know all
of them so
when something bad happens to one of
them you really kind of just like oh man
that dude or whatever
so it's that kind of [ __ ] so after that
happens there's been like little hints
of
supernatural [ __ ] because like i said
you know
like margaret dies like pretty much in
the first you know 10 pages of the book
um you know so you know she's dead and
it gets to a point like just very slowly
over the first half of the book there's
kind of like little hints that
she is kind of gathering up like to come
back like to take revenge right like
the and the way that he describes you
know her
spirit or whatever like coming out of
the water it's almost like she's sort of
like this vengeful
i guess you see it in a lot of horror
movies nowadays but i guess back in 1980
it was kind of like a really
uh a really interesting ghost kind of uh
thing he had going where
she kind of like she's kind of like
made of river silt sort of but then
she's kind of look like looks like a
ghost
as well but then she's also kind of
solid and like i loved his description
of her like coming out of the river and
like forming and stuff and that was like
really really cool
and there's a whole thing too with like
the moon
and how sometimes like when the vengeful
spirits are like after
the murderer they'll be like a weird
they'll go into like a weird nightmarish
dimension like where the moon is like
really really big and it's like shining
down
exactly on you know what it wants you to
see and stuff like that it's almost kind
of like it's causing
hallucinations so it's that kind of
stuff so that's what i mean like all the
the imagery in this like the way he
describes it is like really really
creepy and like really nightmarish
and it's really awesome so from that
point for from the shocking moment
forward
that i was not expecting to happen like
especially that early in the book i was
like holy [ __ ] okay because i thought it
was just gonna be you know margaret dies
and she comes back and like takes
revenge on the person that's you know
cause there's a bunch of [ __ ] going on
in the town like the person they think
is the killer is not the killer and
you know so she's gonna go after the
real guy but then like when there's this
big shocking thing that happens then
there's even more ghosts
and uh you know they start going after
the dude too
and then so from that point forward it's
more it's like a ghostly
revenge type of story it's not like so
like i said don't go into it expecting a
murder mystery because it's not
you find out pretty much immediately uh
who the murderer is
um and then the rest of it is just the
ghosts exacting revenge in particular
ways
and plots and schemes of the murderer to
try to get away with various things and
and all this other stuff so that's kind
of what's going on uh as well
now interestingly like i said now
this if you liked the elementals this is
not quite as weird as that because
like i said that one was a little more
over the top a little weirder like as
far as the imagery went
this one is more like a standard
southern gothic
ghost story um the way he describes the
ghosts is
you know unique uh they look kind of
unique with all this black
water and silts like coming out of this
like i said it's not it's not original
now
because a lot of horror movies have done
that but in 1980 i think it was a little
bit less
you didn't see it as much you know with
like the black eyes and the mouth and
stuff like that
so he was kind of like ahead of his time
i guess um you know so there's that
so yeah but i mean i really loved this i
got super into it like
like i said i could just see the whole
thing happening in front of my eyes and
i just thought it was amazing
now interestingly while i was reading
this
i thought to myself wow it's like this
would probably make a kick-ass
movie because the way he describes the
town and the way he describes the um
the visions and the ghosts and stuff i
was like man that sounds like it would
be really cool
i said but they'd probably [ __ ] it up
and then about an
hour or two after i finished reading the
book i discovered
that they had made a movie adaptation of
this back in 2016.
it's just called cold moon and
it wasn't i don't think it had like a
massive you know theatrical release or
anything like that maybe it did
i feel like the guy that directed it was
i think he had done like some sci-fi
originals like ghost shark
and stuff but it's not as it's not as uh
as bad as that so i mean if i haven't
seen any of his other movies but going
by the titles i was like this was
probably his best one but and it had
actually like a lot of really famous
people in it uh christopher lloyd was in
there not he had like kind of a small
part he played like the dad
uh the guy that owned the bank you know
the dad of
nathan redfield the bank manager or the
bank president
uh he so christopher lloyd was in it uh
frank whaley was in it he played the
sheriff
candy clark was in it she played evelyn
the grandmother um
trying to remember who else weirdly
there was a there was a cameo appearance
by tommy wiseau
i'm not really sure why that was in
there but it's like there's a very brief
scene at the beginning where they're
doing like a rattlesnake rodeo like
they're you know people are
uh rounding up rattlesnakes and they're
like oh you get prizes for like the
biggest one and [ __ ]
the south for whatever reason tommy
wiseau is in there
as kind of like the carnival barker guy
like on this i don't even remember if he
has any lines i think he says something
like you're tearing me apart
mark or lisa or whatever he says he says
something like variation of the famous
line
uh so i was just kind of like okay that
was uh random
you know what i mean so yeah so but he's
in there and uh josh stewart is in it he
plays nathan redfield
and so i decided like about an hour or
two after i finished reading i said what
the hell i'm going to watch the movie
because i found it's free on tubey if
you want to watch it
i didn't love it i think i don't and i
don't know if i just wasn't in the right
mood for it or
if it was because i just finished
reading the book which was so
vivid and so detailed and then i see the
movie and i'm like this really wasn't
the way i was picturing it like this
wasn't
what the people looked like that you
know this wasn't what i was picturing
them looking like
this wasn't what the town picture that i
looked like this is one of the ghosts i
was picturing
so so maybe it was that and also this is
this is a problem that i have a lot like
when i go to see a movie
that's based on a book that i just read
it seems like
everything in the movie is happening
like way too fast because
you know what i mean like i'm watching
people like what the [ __ ] this is
happening already
it's like this was like this is like
two-thirds of the way through the book
through this
before this happened it's only like 20
minutes in the movie this is already
happening
so i mean obviously they had to leave a
lot of [ __ ] out it's actually a fairly
faithful adaptation
they even use like big chunks of
dialogue and stuff the only uh
mass the only like big change was that
margaret the
girl that gets murdered at the beginning
uh in the book she was 14
and in the movie they made her 16 i
guess so it wouldn't be quite so creepy
some of the [ __ ] that uh came to light
later on in the book but
yeah that was like the only major change
that they made everything else was
pretty much the same and like i said
they even used a lot of the way he
described things the way
it wasn't like i said i think the
problem i had with the movie too
other than and that might have been just
me because i just read it and i was just
kind of like
you know this is all happening this is
like they're cramming all of this stuff
in here and it's just like happening too
quickly i didn't really like like the
cgi
was kind of fine it was you know
passable and
i don't know i think that it went too
far over the top
you know what i'm saying because i just
felt like yes it's a southern gothic and
yes i understand that when you do a
southern gothic that's kind of a thing
that everything's like i said sort of
exaggerated
but i don't know i felt like some of the
some of the characters were too
exaggerated
i felt like uh candy clark is evelyn i
think she went a little
over the top christopher lloyd i think
he went kind of way over the top the
girl that played belinda
i've seen her before i mean she's been
in some other stuff she went a little
bit over the top
she was kind of over the top in the book
but not as much and i also kind of
annoyed me too because in the book
belinda who was the sheriff's daughter
and she actually
um she was like 17 i think and she
um looked after the bank owner guy the
you know the one that was in the
wheelchair
so she came and looked after him like
because she wanted to be a nurse or
whatever
and one of the things that she kept
bringing up was that he
he called her his nickname for her was
miss pie
because they were talking about like how
fat she was
and i think even in the book she i don't
think she was actually fat
because she was you know she was like
the teenage like the what do you call it
the cheerleader
leader the cheerleader leader whatever i
don't know what they call that i wasn't
a cheerleader
but so she was so she couldn't have been
that much of a heifer
it's just that i think it was kind of
they were kind of like joking about oh
she
you know she was a little bit chubby or
she was a little bit
uh voluptuous or something and everybody
was kind of making fun of her like she
was fat
so she kept referring to herself as fat
and then
in the movie the girl that they had
playing her was
really not fat so the fact that she was
like
talking about how fat she was and it's
like she brings some clothes to get let
out oh these i wore these 15 pounds ago
i'm like [ __ ] what do you weigh now
like 95
pounds shut the [ __ ] up you know what i
mean so it was it was very weird
so it was that kind of thing the movie
it's not bad and i think if you come
to it i'd be curious like knowing if
people
just watch the movies like i said if you
watch the movie it's on uh to be it's
just called cold
cold moon it's not called cold moon over
babylon i'd be interested to know what
somebody that hadn't read the book
thought about it
because i think part of the reason that
i didn't like it was that i had just
read the book
so i was really aware of everything that
was left out i was really aware of how
it didn't match up with my picturing of
it
and it wasn't really scary or anything
and honestly the book
i thought the book was like really
really creepy like some of the imagery
was like really creepy and just the way
he described it
and it was the same thing with the
elementals like the you know the the
whole
image of like the house like being
buried in the sand and like all the
things coming out of the sand and stuff
it's like it was a similar kind of thing
here like where he was describing the
ghost coming out of the river and
there's one great scene toward the end
where like the killer is
you know kind of brought toward the
cemetery
you know where like the family plot is
and there's a massive moon like shining
over it
and you know it's just just the way he
describes that scene is just so so great
and just like [ __ ] like you know the
killer's driving once and he like loses
time
like he's suddenly on a road that he
doesn't recognize and
you know it just goes on and on and like
the street lights are going out and it
was just like really really cool
i don't know it was just like a really
cool like description of it so i think
that maybe the movie
was just bound to be a letdown because i
think i even thought that before i even
knew there was a movie adaptation of it
when i was reading the book i'm like man
this would probably make a kick-ass
movie
and then i found out oh there was a
movie and then i was like oh what the
hell so i said that i watched it and i
was like
now i kind of wish i hadn't but oh well
it's not that bad and
actually there was um you know there's a
lot of kind of big names in it
it's just that i i don't know i
i think that a good movie could be made
of it but i'm not really sure that that
was that was it it was a passable movie
but i didn't really i didn't really dig
it i just some of the
some of the performances were just a
little too exaggerated
for me and then some of them were kind
of real i mean josh stewart was great in
it he played nathan redfield
but some of the performances i thought
were just a little too
little too much i thought it went a
little a little too far into camp
and uh probably i think they should have
kept it more serious
i don't know because even though you
know that yes there are still like
exaggerated like southern
people in the book too but the book is
pretty
serious and pretty brutal and like some
really terrible [ __ ] like happens in
this book
so you know just know that going in and
like i said nobody in this book main
character whatever
nobody is safe anybody could die so just
know that going into
uh because you'll get attached to the
characters and they'd be like what the
[ __ ] it's like you know what i mean
because so many [ __ ] people die in
this movie and they
earned this book rather and they die in
like really really horrible ways
so you know knowing that too so it's
kind of like it's gory it's creepy
it's just i don't know i loved it and i
just the whole atmosphere of it
was fantastic and i just thought it was
[ __ ] great
uh movie was yeah but you know what are
you gonna do
but you still have the book read the
book instead uh or you can watch the
movie if you want i don't give a [ __ ]
but you know what i mean and like i said
this definitely is not gonna be the last
malcolm uh
malcolm mcdowell that's a totally
different guy uh
michael mcdowell will be reading i
definitely will be doing the amulet at
some point because i have that one as
well
uh but yeah check out cold moon over
babylon and also the elementals which i
reviewed before too if you want to watch
that
i did that a few months ago but yeah
definitely uh check his stuff out i'm
really really glad i mean it's sad that
he
passed away a long time ago but i'm glad
that
his stuff is being rediscovered because
it's
it's really uh outstanding and i really
dig it
so yeah that'll do it for this tomes of
terror and i will see you guys
on the next one bye